Ja, das ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz erstätig. Ich würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir. Das ist ja...
Ja, wenn etwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Paul Münder.
Paul?
Münder.
Herr Münder. Könnten Sie Ihre Nafname bestandieren?
Ja, M, U, also U, UMLAUD, N, D, N, D, E, R.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin noch 69.
69.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18.09.55.
55.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin so 1,74.
1,74.
1,74, okay, okay, Herr Schuldiger.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle, wiegen Sie?
Ja, so ungefähr 83, 84 Kilo.
Ja, das freut mich. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für's Sie zu uns, Herr Münder?
Ja, also wissen Sie, ich habe schon eigentlich seit vielen, vielen Wochen
habe ich am Bein unten so eine offene Stelle.
Und die hat sich aber jetzt in den letzten Tagen
mit einmal sehr, sehr verschlechtert.
Und also die Wunde ist größer geworden
und seit ein paar Tagen läuft da auch so braune Flüssigkeit aus.
Die ist zwar durchsichtig, aber so ein bisschen bräunlich
und das klebt und ja, und was mir eben auch aufgefallen ist,
das ist jetzt schon seit ein paar Tagen,
dass das Bein wirklich angeschwollen ist.
Das tut auch weh, also das spannt so richtig.
Das ist wie so eine pralle Wurst.
Und ja, die Haut war immer so ein bisschen da drum herum.
So gerötet, aber jetzt sieht es ganz dunkelblau aus.
Also das sieht schon ein bisschen schlechter aus als früher.
Das habe ich gedacht, jetzt muss ich aber doch mal vor den Feiertagen zu Ihnen kommen.
Ein Hausarzt hat nämlich Urlaub und dann habe ich gedacht,
ich komme gleich zu Ihnen und krank aus.
Ja, Sie haben sehr gute Entscheidungen getroffen,
hier herzukommen.
Herr Münder, Sie haben sehr viele Informationen,
so schnell sagen, geben.
Ich möchte einen Zusammenpassung machen.
Sie haben sehr, sehr lange Zeit eine Beinoffene Wunde.
Eine offene Wunde, ja, richtig.
Die haben sich letztens groß geworden und braunlich geflüssigt.
Außerdem ist Ihr Bein angeschwollen.
Ist Ihr Bein angeschwollen?
Ja, außer ist Ihr Bein angeschwollen.
Und Spannung?
Ja, das fühlt sich ganz, ganz prall an das Bein, ganz gespannt.
Und letztens ist es dunkel und blauliche Flüssigkeit.
Ja, das sieht jetzt ganz schäußlich aus.
Okay, ist das etwas noch andere?
Ja, das reicht mir völlig.
Es tut natürlich weh.
Am Anfang fand ich das nicht so schlimm,
aber jetzt sind es schon so intensive Schmerzen,
auch wenn man dagegen kommt, tut es weh.
Wenn ich dann da neues Pflaster drauf klebe, tut es eben auf weh.
Und ja, das ist alles so ein bisschen blätterig die Haut darunter.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Münder, wo genau sind die Wunden?
Die ist also am Unterschenkel, da wo der Knöchel am Fuß ist
und auf der Innenseite.
Innenseit.
Welche Bein?
Am rechten Bein.
Ja, wir haben gesagt intensive Schmerzen in letzter Zeit, richtig?
Ja.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Eins bedeuten leichte Schmerzen, die bedeuten unverzlegliche Schmerzen?
Ja, unerträglich.
Ich renne damit jetzt schon eine Weile rum,
aber ja, so auf der Mitte sind die bestimmt von der Intensität die Schmerzen, ja.
So bei 5 von 10 würde ich sagen.
5, okay, verstehe ich.
Und was auch gemein ist, also am Anfang war das nur da unten am Knöchel, ja.
Und jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Schmerzen strahlen so hoch bis in den Unterschenkel rein.
Unterschenkels strahlen.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen ein bisschen beschreiben,
stehlen, ziehlen, dumpfen, drücken?
Dumpf ist das nicht, das ist eher so brennend stechend.
Und natürlich dazu dieses Prahliheitsgefühl, dieses Druckgefühl da drinnen.
Aber die eigentlichen Schmerzen sind eher so weißen, stechend brennend, ja.
Stechend brennend, eigentlich.
Okay.
Herr Münder, haben Sie in letzter Zeit Fieber oder Schutulfrost etwas bemerkt?
Also ich habe mich nicht gemessen, habe ich aber eigentlich auch nicht fieberig gefühlt.
Okay.
Also gemessen habe ich tatsächlich nicht.
Haben Sie das Bedrohnenbereich, Kribbeln gefühlt, Taubheitsgefühl bemerkt?
Nee, sowas, sowas hatte ich nicht, Taubheitsgefühl, nicht.
Ich habe das sehr gut gefühlt, das beiden, das hatte ich gekrippt,
das hat nur weh getan.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen oder die Wut verschlimmert oder linbert?
Naja, also wenn ich dagegen komme natürlich, ja.
Also wenn ich mit, das ist da unten anstoße, wenn ich irgendwo an Stuhlwein komme oder so, ja.
Das tut natürlich dann mehr weh.
Und ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich im Bett liege
und ich ruhig halt eine gute Position gefunden habe, dass die Decke da nicht drauf liegt,
so dann geht es.
Können wir Hochlagerung verbessern sagen oder nicht?
Das könnte sein, dass das damit zusammenhängt, ja, dass es dann hoch liegt, ja.
Haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt, zum Beispiel Husten oder andere Probleme?
Ja, also ich verbinde das ja jetzt schon seit, seit Monaten verbinde ich das immer mit Flästerchen
und, und, und tupft da irgendwie dran rum.
Und ich denke immer, das muss von alleine besser werden, ist ja auch von alleine gekommen.
Aber jetzt wird es halt eben unangenehmer, ja.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstolpern etwas bemerkt?
Nein, nein, also ich habe natürlich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Ich meine, mein Alter, kein Wunder, ja.
Aber mein Herz stolpert nicht, also nüsst ich nicht, nee.
Gut.
Herr Münder, wie ist Ihre Appatit?
Normalerweise ist das nicht gut, ja.
Haben Sie im letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Also ich wieg mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber ich denke mal, das ist so annähernd, okay,
die, die, was die Sachen passen mir alle noch, die Hosenrutschen nicht, also ich habe bestimmt nicht abgenommen.
Okay.
Wie ist, haben Sie Schulgang oder Wasserlassen Probleme?
Einmal Schulgang oder Wasserlassen.
Also nachts muss ich manchmal auf die Toilette zwischendurch, aber eigentlich habe ich da zum Glück noch keine Probleme.
Gut.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen Probleme?
Nein, nein, ich habe nichts mit dem Armen, mir tut nur mein Bein weh.
Okay, okay.
Sie fühlen sich nicht fühlbar, ich verstehe richtig.
Und ich möchte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Münder?
Ja, ich sage dir, ich habe ein bisschen hohem Blutdruck, das hat man halt in meinem Alter, ne.
Also das hat man so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr festgestellt.
Und ja, ich nehme ein paar Medikamente.
Ich glaube, das ist schon gegen den Blutdruck.
Eine ist zu Fenopril und das andere ist HCT 25.
Fenopril, ich verstehe nicht gut.
Zu Fenopril.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends und HCT 25 nehme ich eine morgens.
25.
Eine morgens.
Zu Fenopril, wie viel Milligramm, Erinner, Sie da war?
Oh, was steht denn da drauf auf der Packung?
Ich habe die zu Hause auf dem Estus liegen.
Gibt es das fünf? Kann das sein?
Ja, vielleicht, ich weiß nicht.
Ich muss recherchieren.
Und müssen Sie bei meinem Hausarzt anrufen.
Okay, Hausarzt sagen.
Noch andere chronische Erkrankungen leiden Sie?
Ja, also ich trage ja mein Hörgerät.
Auf der linken Seite vor allen Dingen.
Und da habe ich leicht mal so Mittelohreinzündungen.
Da habe ich immer mal wieder Probleme.
Sie tragen jetzt Hörgerät?
Ja.
Noch andere?
Nein, nein, nein, sonst habe ich gesagt, ich bin nicht operiert.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Das muss ich richtig überlegen.
Nein, tatsächlich bin ich so noch komplett.
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Gut.
Herr Nünder, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf
oder diese zwei Medikamente, noch andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme noch einmal am Tag aspirin 100.
Und zwar hatte ich vor Jahren,
ich habe dann, ich glaube, 5 Jahre her,
in dem rechten Bein eine Trombose.
Und dann habe ich eine Zeit lang
einen Glutverdünner genommen und auch Strümpfe getragen.
Und dann nach einer Weile, nach einem halben Jahr,
haben wir das dann ausgeschlichen.
Und sollte ich aber noch aspirin regelmäßig nehmen.
Das verschreibt mir mein Hausarzt immer.
Haben Sie wie immer, gibt es Krampf oder im Irre bei?
Jetzt kann ich da nichts sehen.
Das Bein ist so dick, dass man da keine Krampfarren sehen kann.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverzweglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, also ich darf auf keinen Fall Fisch
und so Krabben und so Zeug essen und muscheln.
Und dann kann ich überhaupt mich vertragen
und auf eine Hand kremen.
Bitte?
Genau, so kann man das sagen.
Und auf eine Handcreme habe ich mal so ganz heftig reagiert.
Da hatte ich mal nach der Gartenarbeit so trockene Hände
und habe mir die Hände eingekremen
und da wurde es immer schlimmer.
Deswegen nehme ich keine Handcreme mehr.
Schlimmer bedeutet Rötung oder...
Das hat gejuckt und war gerötet.
Das war nicht so angenehm.
Okay.
Wenn Sie mehrere Früchte essen, wie reagieren Sie?
Ja, also das ist einmal passiert,
dass ich so ein rotes Gesicht bekommen habe
und auch ein bisschen schwer Luft bekommen habe.
Und dann war da...
Also bin ich gleich in die Klinik gekommen
und Sie haben mir dann so ein Medikament dagegen,
gegen Allergien gegeben
und dann hat sich das aber wieder beruhigt.
Ja, Ihre Zunge hat große geworden.
Ja, also ich hatte so das Gefühl,
dass ich tatsächlich nicht beruhigt habe.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Herr Münder, könnten Sie mir bitte sagen,
ob Sie da auch rühren?
Jetzt schon viele, viele, viele Jahre nicht mehr.
Also ich habe vor fast 20 Jahren aufgehört.
20 Jahre?
Bitte?
Seit 20 Jahren aufgehört.
Ja, knapp 20 Jahre, ja.
Aber davor habe ich auch 30 Jahre im Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke häufiger mal ein Bier ab
und wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt,
auch mal ein Glas mehr, aber also nicht viel.
Nicht viel, okay, vielen Dank.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt oder Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Ich?
Nein, also wirklich nicht nein.
Nein, gut.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch lieben?
Das wäre sehr erstaunlich,
also die müssten ja fast 100 sein.
Nein, nein, die sind beide gestorben.
Okay, leiden Sie, haben Sie chronische Erkrankung erlitten?
Also, die waren bestimmt zum Schluss nicht gesund.
Also mein Vater hatte irgendwas an der Galle.
Da haben die gesagt, also in den Gallengängen gab es Tumore
und das hat ihm damals so zu schaffen gemacht.
Und ich glaube, daran ist er auch gestorben.
Und meine Mutter, die hatte ein Darm große Probleme.
Die hat dann auch kurz vor ihrem Tod noch
einen künstlichen Darmausgang bekommen.
Aber da hat sie nicht mehr lange mitgelebt.
Wegen Krebs, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht genau, ob das tatsächlich Krebs war
oder irgendeine andere Erkrankung.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich bin ein sehr kind.
Ein sehr kindgut.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Nein, ich bin ein Begründer.
Rentner.
Früher, was haben Sie gemacht?
Ich war Angestellter in der Stadtverwaltung.
Stadtverwaltung, ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon groß.
Ich habe einen Hinklekid.
Sind Sie gesund oder haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also die sind pukken gesund.
Ja, ja, nein, geht es allen gut.
Gut, perfekt.
Herr Milder, haben Sie vollständig geimpft
in besonderen Corona- und Kinderheitserkrankungen?
Kinder, Kindererkrankungen.
Also, puh, das ist ja nur schon eine Weile her bei mir.
Aber ich denke mal, seinerzeit habe ich da alle Impfungen bekommen.
Und jetzt, Corona bin ich natürlich auch 3- oder sogar 4-mal geimpft worden.
Gut.
Waren Sie im letzten Zeit Ausland?
Im Ausland?
Nein, das kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben.
Wie wissen Sie, meine Frau sitzt im Rollstuhl.
Und ich muss die eigentlich betreuen.
Da können wir gar nicht gut wegfahren.
Okay.
Verbringen Sie zu viel Zeit, sitzen oder stehend bleiben?
Ja, ich leide jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag in der Gegend rum.
Ja, okay.
Alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ach, jetzt habe ich Ihnen ja auch eine Menge Zeug erzählt.
Ja, wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen könnte.
Ja, ich glaube, also was mich jetzt natürlich interessiert,
ja, woher kommt das, was kann man dagegen machen?
Ja, wir können eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen
und Laboruntersuchen und vielleicht Miliegebinde-Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann entscheiden wir die genaue Diagnose.
Okay, und dann sagen Sie mir auch, was man tun kann.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist gut, ja.
Gut, hat noch jemand Fragen?
Alle völlig fraglos.
Haben Sie Haarausfall, haben Sie Haarausfall, umgebung der Wunde?
Hm, das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen, aber das stimmt, da wo das so prall ist,
da sind eigentlich nicht mehr viele Haare, das haben Sie schon recht, ja.
Entschuldige, noch andere Frage, stelle ich, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie groß die Wunde?
Ah, ja.
Also früher war die wie so ein Zehntzendstück, ganz am Anfang.
Und jetzt ist sie vielleicht so 3,5, 4 Zentimeter im Durchmesser,
ist richtig groß geworden.
3 bis 4.
3 bis 4 Zentimeter im Durchmesser, ja.
3 bis 4 Zentimeter im Durchmesser, okay.
Und kommt von der Wunde Ausfluss oder Eitrig?
Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass da so klare Flüssigkeit runterläuft.
Mit einmal, das war aber früher nicht, das ist neu, dass da so Wasser rausfließt, ja.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit Verletzung im rechten Bein?
Also ich, also irgendwann mal habe ich mich da verletzt und damit hat es angefangen.
Dann habe ich das halt immer verflastert und das halt nicht heilen wollen,
dann ist es jetzt immer schlimmer geworden.
Ganz am Anfang fing das bestimmt an, ich glaube beim Fahrradfahren bin ich abgerutscht
und dann bin ich dann an die Pedale gekommen, so was in der Art war das.
Okay, danke.
Ist diese Fall erst mal aufgetreten oder früher?
Früher habe ich so was nicht gehabt, früher habe ich das nicht gehabt, ja.
Ich habe mir natürlich früher auch schon mal an den Beinen eben für so Wunden geholt,
aber das das ewig nicht heilt, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Für mich erst einmal, ja.
Mögen Sie rauslegen?
Ja, können wir aufhören, ja gut.
Ich möchte eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Frau Herr Paul Münder ist ein 69-jähriger Patient,
zeitlich örtlich und persönlich vollständig orientiert,
in leicht übergewichtigen Ernährungszustand und beschwerde Bedingte leicht reduziert am Allgemeinszustand.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns seit langer Zeit bestehende,
persistierende, progrediente, medial, malleol, schmerzhafte Ulzeration.
Die Schmerzen würden unterschenken, auszutragen.
In den Unterküchern auszutragen.
Die Intensität der Schmerzen wurde mit fünf von Zin auf eine nummerische Skala angegeben.
Die Wunder, offene Wunder oder die Ulzeration seien in letzter Zeit große geworden.
Am Anfang war es, sei sie ungefähr zehn Millimeter große gewissen,
aber sie haben ungefähr drei bis vier Zentimeter durchmesser, vergrößt.
Vergrößt? Hat sich auch so auf drei Zentimeter vergrößt?
Ja, vergrößt. Die Ulzeration seien braunlich Flüssigkeit und außerdem glatt.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Entschuldige, ja.
Die Ulzeration seien braunlich...
Braunlich... Entschuldige.
Die Ulzeration nässt.
Nässt, die Ulzeration nässt.
Ja, das passt.
Nässt, äh, braunlich...
Braunliche Flüssigkeit, ja.
Ja, vielleicht braunliche Flüssigkeit, ja.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über rechte Bein ödämisch, woelene
und außerdem dunkel und blaule Kruste.
Kruste?
Ja, auf die Wunder.
Ja, reden wir gleich darüber.
Und die Frage, auf die Frage nach Pirexie, Schutteufroß, Taubheiß oder Kribbelngefühl,
wurde verneint.
Wir sind ein bisschen beim Hochlagerung gelindert.
Und ja, die Bestiefe an einem Nässt, ist auch oben genannte Symptome, unauffällig.
Auf die Frage nach Gewichtverlust oder Schlafprobleme,
Schuttegang und Massellassenprobleme wurde verneint.
Antwort Erkrankungen, leider sie, leider er, seit 10 Jahre, arteriale Hypertonie,
die zu von April zweimal täglich und HZT 25 Milligramm einmal täglich eingestellt worden sei.
Außerdem trage sie habe, er habe Mittelohrenzündung erlitten, deswegen trage eine Hörgerät.
Umgekehrt. Durch das Mittelohrenzündung wird immer wieder eine Mittelohrenzündung ausgelöst.
Und sie bei ihm wurde keine Operation durchgeführt.
Es wurde noch keine Operation durchgeführt.
In Bezug auf Medikation, nehme er derzeit die schon genannte Medikamente
und es ist 100 Milligramm einmal täglich seit fünf Jahren, ja, seit fünf Jahren ein.
Deswegen, vor fünf Jahren habe er eine rechte Beintrombose erlitten, deswegen habe er Blutverdünnung und Kompression Stümpfe benutzt.
Und jetzt trägt er nur, ist er nicht der Ort, die er kriegt.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten gab der Patient an, auf mehreres Früchte mit allergisch Schock,
eine allergische Schock zu reagieren.
Aus der Demhabe er eine Handcreme allergie trete mit erlitten und pruritisch Darauf.
Er berichtete, seit 20 Jahren nicht traurig zu sein, davon ungefähr 30 Jahre habe er ein Paket Zigarette täglich geraucht.
Er trinkte ein Flaschbierabend und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
An Familien an Amnese ergab eine Galemblase Karzinom.
Ich erinnere nicht die Fachbegriffe Galem, da er verstorben ist.
Die Mutter des Patienten, leider an Darmerkrankungen, aber nachher ist es nicht bekannt, sie habe deswegen eine Kolostomie.
Wollen wir die noch liten? Nein.
Also litten sie? Erlitten, entschuldige.
Also sie litt an einer Darmerkrankung und hat eine Kolostomie bekommen und eine Spräteranlage.
Und sie sei Einzelkind, sie sei Renterin.
Ja, ja, ja, sie sind mal noch ein Mann.
Er sei Einzelkind und Renterin. Er sei verheiratet, habe gesunde drei Kinder.
Er habe als Engelstadt Verhaltung gearbeitet.
Er sei vollständig geimpft, Reise an einem Nuss war unauffällig.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf eine Ulkus Kururis hin.
Was werdet ihr an, Ulkus Kururis?
Ulkus Kururis dafür ist langzeitige offene Wunder.
Ich frage, ein Venöses oder ein Artejelles?
Venöses.
Wir haben früher Venöse-Trombose Probleme.
Er hatte schon in den Beinen eine Trombo.
Alternative kommen die Folgen der Erkrankungen in Betracht.
Alternative Trombo-Flebitis,
ja, Elisapel oder Len Fangid.
Noch mal?
Len Fangid.
Len Fangidis.
Er hat keine Diabetes-Mendetouche.
Er hat keinen beschrieben, es gibt Diabetes-Fußsyndrom.
Ich erinnere nicht daran.
Welche Diabetes-Mendetouche?
Welche?
Gut, also wir gucken.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten? Diagnostisch?
Diagnostisch.
Zuerst sollen wir körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Als körperliche Untersuchungen werde ich zuerst
Vikalparameter kontrollieren, insbesondere FIBA.
Er leide an Bluthochdruck,
Arterial-Hypertoni, deswegen sollen wir
Ihre Blutdruck wieder kontrollieren.
Ausserdem bei der Inspektion überprüfe,
achte ich auf Ihre Bein- und Hunde-Schwellung
oder Hautveränderungen und andere Probleme.
Gucken Sie nur das rechte Bein an.
Nein, ich vergleiche beide Beine mit einem anderen.
Wichtig, der Seitenvergleich.
Sondern auf Temperatur, Körpertemperatur und Dich.
Schwellung, ja.
Ich messe die Umfang.
Ja, Sie messen den Umfang, genau.
Was gucken Sie noch?
Bei der Pasion soll ich Pulse,
unterschenkel Pulse kontrollieren.
Insbesondere Dorsalis, Pedi
und Artibialis Dorsalis Pulse kontrollieren.
Vielleicht meine Verdachtdiagnose POVK.
Ja, das wäre ein Artibialis Pulse.
Ich Pulse kontrolliere.
Und das machen Sie weiter?
Sollen wir Ihre Lunge abhören?
Vielleicht gibt es eine Envolu oder andere Probleme.
Sie haben keine Wusten oder andere Probleme.
Ja, der hat es nicht beschrieben.
Als Laboruntersuchung werde ich Blut abnehmen
und ein paar Laboruntersuchungen durchführen.
Welche denn?
Blutbild, Entzündung, Parameter, CSP, BESG,
CRP, CRP, BESG
und die die mehr Gerinnungsparameter.
Sehr gut.
Und ja, vielleicht Sie, ja, vielleicht, ja.
Was untersuchen Sie noch im Labor?
Labor, Gerinnungsparameter, die die mehr, ja,
ich erinnere nicht daran.
Vielleicht, richtig, glixierte Hemoglobin,
vielleicht für Diabetes.
Genau, also einmal das.
Ja, aber was lassen Sie im Labor noch untersuchen?
Außer dem Blut?
Außer dem Blut, sollen wir, ich sage,
außer dem, sollen wir,
absolut und kulturwunder.
Aus der Wunde, ein Abstrich aus der Wunde, ja.
Abschuldig, absolut.
Unter Mikroskop oder als Kultur.
Das Kultur und das, was man sieht, was da wächst, genau.
Und als illgebente Verfahren,
sollen wir doppelere Sonographie durchführen.
Bei der Bein und vielleicht brauchen wir eine
zwei ebenden Röntgenaufnahme,
Beinprobleme oder nicht.
Früher hat man flevografiert, aber eigentlich macht man das
heute gar nicht mehr, weil die,
weil die Ultraschallengeräte eigentlich so gut sind,
dass man da alles sehen kann, beziehungsweise,
wenn man die Thrombose ausschließen will,
dann hat man den DD mehr wert, dann ist es eigentlich auch eindeutig.
Na gut, okay, gut.
Ja, wenn ich das jetzt bestätigt,
dass der tersächlichen Venöses Ulcos hat,
wie wären denn die Behandlungsschritte?
Haben Sie deine Ideen?
Ja, die Behandlung richtet sich nach
die Untersuchung Ergebnisse
und die Schwergrad, vielleicht,
wie sollen eine Schmerzmittel
und antibiotische Therapie verabreichen?
Und vielleicht noch etwas?
Was machen Sie denn mit dem Bein?
Bein geschworen, ne?
Ja, Sie sind auch im richtigen Weg.
Ja, wie empfehlen, wie sollen
Kompression Therapie, deswegen
Kompression Strufe oder Kompression Verband?
Erstmal Verband, solange das Bein dick ist, vor allem.
Als Proflaktik sollen wir
Trombose-Proflaxie durchführen.
Und umstellen, ja, wenn da jetzt liegt, ja.
Und natürlich muss mit der Wunde was passieren, ne?
Ja.
Der braucht ja saugfähige Auflagen,
die dieses Sekret auffangen.
Sollen wir eine schulische Konzil- und
operästische Therapie machen?
Das kann man sicherlich machen,
gefilbschirurgisches Konzil, klar, ja.
Aber zunächst mal muss der tatsächlich
eine Wundauflage haben, die sauber ist
und die groß genug ist und die nicht
verklebt mit der Wunde und die
entsprechend in der Lage ist, die Feuchtigkeit
aufzusaugen.
Und dann, ja, es kommen viele Tipps jetzt,
die Rede ist gewesen hier vom Dépré-Démain.
Das wäre also, wenn da die großen sind
runter rum, könnte man natürlich das entfernen.
Und wenn es eine sehr hardnäckige Wunde ist,
die so nicht verheilen will unter Kompression,
wäre Wackkompens Therapie auch noch eine Option.
Ja, aber erst sollen wir einfacher Therapie...
Ja, also erste Schritte auf eine Stelle.
Wundauflage und Kompression, ganz entscheidend.
Wundauflage und ja.
Ja, gut.
Okay, ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden
über den Herrn Wünder und nehmen wir den
jetzt stationär auf oder kann der nach Hause gehen?
In diesem Fall kann es keine stationäre Aufnahme
ich denke, ja, wir können in der Ambulanz behandeln.
Genau, dass er regelmäßig kommt, aber sich im
Regel nicht sich vorstellen kann.
Vielleicht, wenn wir Wunder schlimmer werden,
können wir stationäre Aufnahme...
Klingt nach einem vernünftigen Vorgehen.
Genau, ja, sehr gut.
Okay, gut.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Sie haben gemerkt, ich bin ein bisschen eingestiegen,
wenn es mir sprachlich zu wild wurde.
Ja, dann habe ich gleich eingegriffen,
damit es nicht erst in Vergessenheit gerät.
Man versteht ja, was sie wollen und was sie meinen.
Man kann das immer gut verstehen, aber es ist nicht
immer alles grammatikalisch richtig.
Habe ich Ihnen letztes Mal auch schon gesagt.
Was?
Ja, zum Beispiel...
Ich glaube, das habe ich letztes Mal Ihnen schon gesagt.
Erleitet an Hypertrophie.
Ja, das fehlt halt ein bisschen was.
Ansonsten haben Sie eigentlich eine schöne,
vollständige Anamnese gemacht.
Sie haben gemerkt, der Patient wurde so ein bisschen
ungeduldig, als Sie nach Herzbeschwerden gefragt haben.
Da hat er gesagt, wenn ich mein Bein tut,
was soll denn das?
So ungefähr.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen dieser Punkt.
Wenn man den gesamten Fragenkatalog abfragt,
dann je nachdem, was der Patient hat,
versteht er vielleicht nicht zwingend,
warum jetzt diese Frage gestellt wird.
Und da kann man vielleicht auch nochmal so ein bisschen
geleckend dann was sagen dazu, dass man sagt,
ja, das mag Ihnen jetzt überflüssig vorkommen,
ich möchte ein Bild von Ihrem gesamten Gesundheitszustand
bekommen, deswegen muss ich auch das abfragen,
irgendwie so was in der Richtung.
Ja, was Ihnen nicht so ganz gelungen ist,
dieses Spannungsgefühl in dem Bein zu schildern,
dass das Bein musigmatisiert ist und dass die Haut sich verfärbt,
dass die Haut dunkel wird.
Der hat da keine dunkelblauen Krust,
sondern praktisch das ganze Bein,
und das hat ihn ja auch erschreckt eigentlich,
deswegen ist er gekommen, weil das die Haut mit einmal dunkel wird.
Ja, und das sind natürlich Dinge,
auf die man dann auch in der Untersuchung schaut,
dass man sagt natürlich Umfang für Dematisierung
im Seitenvergleich und dann natürlich auch
Kolorit im Seitenvergleich.
Ist das eine Bein blauer als das andere,
ja, oder dunklergefähr?
Ja, und gibt es sonstige Hautveränderungen
in der Umgebung?
Ja, und bei der patienten Vorstellung
sind Sie am Anfang so ein bisschen in Schwimmen gekommen.
Ich habe sie erst nicht so ganz verstanden,
aber ich muss hier gerade fliegen hier haben.
Ich habe sie nicht ganz verstanden,
aber sie stellte sich vor Wegen.
Das ist ja immer die kritische Geschichte.
Wenn sie Wegen sagen,
müssen sie leider Gottes auch den Genitiv benutzen.
Das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig,
weil wir nicht viel Training haben
mit dem Genitiv im Deutschen.
Also, er stellte sich vor,
wegen einer Ulzeration am linken Maleolus,
und sie haben da glaube ich auch nur Maleolus gesagt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, wie sie es in der Türkei sagen,
nämlich keine Ahnung.
Ja, also am linken Maleolus
und mit zunehmender Ulzeration,
mit zunehmender Schmerzhaftigkeit
und mit Austrahlung in den Unterschenkel.
Es strahlt etwas wohin?
Wir müssen sie immer sagen, in eine Richtung.
Es strahlt immer in eine Richtung.
Wenn es überhaupt strahlt,
das muss man aber dann auch so formulieren.
Ja, aber ansonsten würde ich mal sagen,
konnten wir uns wirklich gut verstehen,
Sie haben die ganzen Besonderheiten des Patienten eigentlich schon gut erwähnt.
Die Allergien, die Noxen, familiäre Situationen,
Familie in einer Mese.
Also er hat gesagt, beide Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Und wenn jemand verstorben ist,
wir wissen nicht viel über chronische Erkrankungen der Eltern.
Wir wissen nur, die Mutter hatte eine Darmerkrankung
und ist an der verstorben auch.
Und der Vater hatte diese Tumorerkrankung.
Was da sonst noch war, wissen wir halt nicht.
Oftmals wissen erwachsende Kinder nicht,
woran ihre uralten Eltern sterben.
Nicht alle sind im Bilde.
Ja.
Was fehlt ja an Diagnosen?
Das ist aber von Ihren Kollegen auch noch erwähnt worden,
dass der unter Umständen Hautkrebs hat.
An den nicht teilhändigen Wunden,
könnte man natürlich auch immer für den Karzinom sprechen.
So wollte man zumindest erwähnen in der Geschichte.
Ja, natürlich.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass Sie in Münster mit einem Ulkos belästigt werden,
ist wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr groß.
Sie werden eher, denke ich mal,
was aus der großen internistischen Kiste bekommen.
Normalerweise Düsseldorf und Münster machen
überwiegend so internistische Geschichten.
Aber mal gucken, was Ihnen tatsächlich begegnet.
Und Sie haben natürlich den großen,
großen Vorteil, dass Sie aus der klinischen Erfahrung
eigentlich sehr, sehr viel schildern können
und wissen und darauf eingehen können
und nachfragen können.
Denken mal, pokern Sie einfach mit diesem Plus,
was Sie haben.
Das ist die Erfahrung, die klinische Erfahrung
und auch die klinische Erfahrung in einer deutschen Klinik.
Dass Sie also auch da mit Leuten schon gesprochen haben,
wie sehr die jetzt auf die sprachlichen Feinheiten
was Grammatik angeht, abheben werden.
Ich kann es Ihnen nicht versprechen.
Ich sage mal so viel.
Wir halten kollektiv die Daumen,
dass alles gut geht am Donnerstag.
Alle Kollegen, die heute hier sind, halten mit.
Vielen Dank.
Wir sind natürlich gespannt, was Sie erzählen hinterher.
Kurzes Statement an Dr. Pupil oder an Dr. Gündes wäre super,
dass wir beschalten, wie es für Sie ausgegangen ist.
Bleiben Sie entspannt und wir wünschen Ihnen alles Gute für Donnerstag.
Vielen Dank.
Und die anderen, wir sehen uns am Donnerstagabend.
Guck mal, ja.
An alle, viel Erfolg.
Gut, Ihnen allen heute einen schönen Abend
und wir sehen uns übermorgen.
Okay.